[Musique]
deux maires une ancienne députée un
pompier et un astronaute décoré quatre
ivelinois ont été distingués lors de la
traditionnelle promotion du Nouvel An de
la Légion d'Honneur jean-if Perro maire
de marli Leroi conseiller maître à la
Cour des Comptes est élevé au grade
d'officier la maèire de la Boissière
école Anne Françoise Guillot est faite
chevalier dernière élu distingué
Françoise Descamp Cronier député PS de
la 8e circonscription des ivelines entre
2012 et 2017 elle a été nommée chevalier
sur proposition d'urore berger des
engagements reconnus aussi du côté des
pompiers Stéphane mot le directeur
départemental du 1078 et promu Chevalier
dernière yvelinois récompensé
Jean-François clairvois le spaonaut
français accède quant à lui au Grad de
Commandeur il a passé 28 jours dans
l'espace à l'occasion de trois missions
qui dit nouvelle année dit vœux et les
ivelinois rivalisent d'imagination pour
les présenter à Verneuil sur scène
fabien aurcheteur a fait appel à son
avatar une vidéo 100 % intelligence
artificielle pour illustrer notamment
sur le risque des deep fake coutumier du
fait carlolive a une nouvelle fois
choisi vidéo et chant pour célébrer 2024
avec le regard vers les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques
chante la vie
chante comme si tu devais mourir
demain comme si plus rien avait
d'importance chant
oui
[Musique]
chante toujours plus de nouveaux
ivelinois le département reste le plus
peuplé de la grande couronne d'après les
chiffres de l'INC entre 2015 et 2021
l'augmentation est de + 0,3 % il y a
donc désormais 1,45 millions d'ivelinois
la ville connaissant la plus grande
croissance s CIN sur l'école avec 2,4 %
d'augmentation démographique près de 250
cartes de démarrage dérobé un employé de
l'usine Renault à fin sur scène a été
interpellé le 29 décembre au soir le
site était sous surveillance depuis
plusieurs semaines selon nos confrères
de cette utactu l'employé devrait être
jugé prochainement au cours d'une
comparution sur reconnaissance préalable
de
culpabilité